a la altura de un triángulo es cuatro
centímetros menos que el largo de su
base si el área del triángulo es de 30
centímetros cuadrados encuentra la base
la altura del triángulo usa la fórmula
área es igual a un metro de base por
altura para encontrar el área del
triángulo y bien cómo resolvemos este
problema lo primero que voy a hacer aquí
es dibujar un triángulo para que veamos
cuánto debe de valer su base y cuánto
debe de valer su altura
voy a suponer que su base vale b esto es
lo que vale la longitud de su base
mientras que su altura va a valer h la
longitud de su altura es h y yo sé que
para sacar el área de un triángulo
necesito la fórmula área es igual a un
medio de base por altura hasta aquí todo
lo hemos visto pero quiero que chequen
el primer renglón de este problema que
dice la altura de un triángulo es 4
centímetros menos que la longitud de su
base es decir como la longitud de su
base vale b entonces la altura es lo
mismo que de menos 4 y entonces ya puedo
yo plantear una ecuación cuadrática
fíjense bien 30 que es el
área que nos dice que tiene el triángulo
30 centímetros cuadrados es igual a un
medio de la base un medio por la base
por la altura pero la altura en este
caso es igual a menos 4 por lo tanto en
lugar de altura voy a sustituir el valor
de la altura que es de menos 4 y
entonces ahora si ya tengo una ecuación
que resolver para b y perfecto porque ya
tenemos la ecuación de este problema y
es que muchas veces esto es lo más
difícil de resolver un problema y
entonces que quedan 30 es igual a un
medio por b por b menos 4 y dejan de
escribir lo mejor así así se va a ver
mucho más claro primero voy a
multiplicar el 2 medio por ver y me va a
quedar de medios que multiplica a b
menos 4 y ahora voy a distribuir el de
medios por cada uno de los dos términos
de este binomio y me queda b cuadrado de
entre 4 no no no no nos pueden entre 2
hay que tener mucho cuidado y después me
va a quedar menos 4 entre dos es 2
entonces me queda menos 2 b
ya continuación para que no me quede
este término debe cuadrada entre 2 y no
me queden fracciones no tuve sed es
multiplicar todo por 2 esta parte por 2
y esta parte por 22 por 30 y 60 es igual
a 2 por b cuadrado entre 2 estos b
cuadrada y 2 por todos son 4 entonces me
queda menos 4 b y bueno
recuerden que les he contado que lo
mejor es ver las ecuaciones cuadráticas
igualadas a cero por lo tanto lo que voy
a hacer es restar de ambos lados de la
ecuación 60 para que me quede una
ecuación cuadrática igual a cero lo que
tenemos que saber es el valor de esta
ecuación por lo tanto menos 60 de un
lado y menos 60 del otro 60 y 60 se van
y me queda de cuadrada menos 4 b menos
60 y ahora si esto es igual a 0 y es
justo lo que yo quería ya esta ecuación
cuadrática la quiero resolver por el
método de factorización es decir tras lo
que voy está actualizar esta expresión
que tengo aquí en dos binomios tales que
al multiplicarse me den igual a cero lo
que quiere decir que o el primer binomio
cero o el segundo binomio cero lo cual
me va a ayudar a resolver
esta ecuación pero bueno para fac
turista de esa expresión voy a buscar
dos números que al sumar se me den menos
4 y al multiplicar se me den menos 60
así que vamos a notarlo
me tienen que dar menos 4 y ya por ver
me tiene que dar menos 62 números que
suma 2 menos 4 y que multiplicados me
den menos 60 y ya con esto se ve mucho
más claro que es lo que quiero entonces
ahora si lo primero que quiero que
veamos es que a x b tiene que ser menos
60 por lo tanto uno de los dos números
tiene que ser positivo y el otro tiene
que ser negativo el 60 lo puede
descomponer en 160 pero están muy lejos
todos números pues si buscamos su
diferencia es 59 y eso está muy lejos
del -4 otra descomposición es 2 y 30
pero su diferencia es 28 y también sigue
muy lejos 3 y 20 pero 20 menos 3 17
todavía seguimos muy lejos son números
muy lejanos a ver vamos a ver 4 y 15 4 y
15 la diferencia es 15 menos 4 que es 11
también seguimos muy lejos
5 y 12 5 y 12 5 x 12 60 pero 12 5 es 7
ya nos vamos acercando ya nos vamos
acercando a ver vamos a ver 6 6 que
multiplica a 10 es 60 y 10 664 perfecto
ya tengo aquí que es 6 y 10 solamente
como mi resultado tiene que ser menos 4
el negativo para que gane tiene que ser
el 10 entonces voy a quedar 6 y menos 10
y entonces esto ya me da pie a que yo
pueda escribir esta ecuación de la
siguiente manera de más 6 que multiplica
a b menos 10 y ya estoy factor izando
esta ecuación cuadrática que yo tenía
aquí arriba y ahora sí ya tengo dos
binomios que están multiplicando y que
son igual a cero y bueno hay que tener
mucho cuidado porque esta vez no es lo
mismo que esta vez esta vez significa la
longitud de mi base y esta vez lo puse
para poner los números que buscábamos es
más no me gustaría que nos confundiremos
buscábamos dos números que su suma tenía
que ser igual a menos 4 y que su
multiplicación tuviera que ser menos 60
y no tienen nada que ver con la base de
mi triángulo
así que mejor no voy a poner como x y 10
x es igual a menos 4 y x x y es igual a
menos 60 pero en fin también otra cosa
que les quería comentar es que esta
misma factorización pudimos obtenerla
por agrupación sin embargo ya que la
obtenemos ahora qué vamos a hacer
tenemos dos binomios que multiplicaban
los lanceros y dos cosas multiplicarán
los lanceros y la primera cero o en su
dado caso la segunda es cero si la
primera fuera cero entonces me quedaría
que más 6 es igual a 0 y si la segunda
fuera 0 me quedaría que menos 10 es
igual a 0 y bueno ya de aquí puedo
resolver para ver me va a quedar que b
es igual a menos 6 o en su dado caso si
yo paso el 10 del otro lado no va a
quedar que b es igual a 10 pero positivo
y ya que tengo mis dos raíces o mis dos
soluciones de esta ecuación tanto b
igual a menos 6 como b igual a 10
solucionan esta ecuación cuadrática que
yo tenía aquí y ya llegué al resultado
no hay que tener cuidado porque también
es muy importante revisar que mi
solución sea congruente con lo que se
está planteando en el problema pero
antes que eso déjame ponerlo también
aquí por agrupación para qué
y llegamos al mismo resultado que la 0
es igual a b cuadrada 6 b que era uno de
los dos números que habíamos encontrado
menos 10 b el cual era el otro número
que habíamos encontrado menos 60 y
entonces voy a factorizar los primeros
dos términos de esta ecuación y le voy a
sacar factor común el factor común es b
que multiplica de más 6 y en los otros
dos términos también le voy a sacar
factor común y es factor común es menos
10 que multiplica de más 6 y aquí si te
das cuenta tengo ve más 6 y demás 6
demás leyes por lo tanto es un factor
común de esta expresión que tengo aquí
por lo tanto me va a quedar de menos 10
que multiplica además 6 porque de más 6
era factor común y los otros dos
términos eran b y menos 10 y si te das
cuenta llegamos a lo mismo aquí está muy
factor común y me queda b menos 10 que
multiplica además 6 que era justo lo que
teníamos aquí abajo solamente que que
abajo lo hicimos en un solo paso es lo
mismo tú puedes utilizar el método que
más te sirva o en el cual te acomodes
mejor y bueno ya que tengo mis dos
posibles resultados debe quiero ver cuál
es congruente con el problema porque
date cuenta si le vas
-6 entonces esto no tendrá sentido
porque tendríamos un lado negativo y no
conozco ningún triángulo con lados
negativos no podemos tener longitudes
negativas y si b vale 10 entonces sí nos
queda de resultado por lo tanto esto lo
voy a tachar este no me sirve porque no
tenemos lados negativos y me quedo con
que b es igual a 10 y sirve vale 10 eso
quiere decir que la base vale 10 y
entonces la altura vale 10 menos 4 lo
cuales seis ya tengo que la altura vale
6 la base vale 10 y sería bueno
rectificar si realmente estamos haciendo
el procedimiento correcto me quedaría 10
por 6 me da 60 60 entre 2 son 30
centímetros cuadrados y perfecto
logramos resolver este problema